I see what's an orchestrate
changing the concepts of the future of
work so this new kind of concept of
digital workers
um is a really it's a new definition of
it so people when you talk to them about
digital workers do they mean a chatbot
do they mean a robot and I think up
until very recently that was basically
what most of us thought
the New Concept of digital worker that
we're now really evolving using this
tool called Watson orchestrate
is something very different to that and
imagine it's like you getting somebody
new in your team the old kind of digital
worker through chat would do one thing
and one thing well so it would answer a
query it would maybe find your policy
May simplify a task through chat but as
soon as you switched it off it would
forget you ever existed
digital worker doesn't and that's the
big big shift now something like Watson
orchestrate brings is it has a memory
and it can remember and it can learn and
nothing I've ever seen has ever done
that before it took us a while to get
our head round the shift in thinking
around it's a digital worker that's
different than a chatbot or a robot once
they taught us that difference
it that the ideas that we had just kind
of exploded it was like this is
different and therefore
instead of it doing one thing at a time
we could get it to run and manage a
program they were really interested in
saying can this digital worker come in
and automate the bits that a manual do
all the high volume stuff take away the
admin that actually they felt was adding
no value when they did themselves as
humans but one really interesting thing
that we learned when we got managers to
try this in our production system was
they said oh this is really cool we love
this it's it's making our life easier
it's simplifying it's helping us make
better decisions and the manager said
this gives us information that we can go
back to our employees and Coach them
better than we've everyone else to do so
here was making a huge kind of
difference around efficiency and
effectiveness
is doing a big leap in experience for
managers Talent Partners the workday Coe
Etc
but it's also making managers better
coaches and that's the bit we had no
idea was going to do that there is no
reason whatsoever why exactly the same
thing can't happen in finance
while you can't have a digital worker do
a quote to class process
we know that sales is a great
opportunity where a sales administrator
through a digital worker will bring
information to a salesperson when they
need it where they need it in whatever
order they need it and we'll go off and
coordinate to whole series of activities
and background to the salesperson just
needs to sell the workforce challenge is
always
too busy doing stuff to be strategic and
get ready for the future orchestrate
will help us stop having to do stuff and
allow us to think a lot more